This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I fell of Americans. Memorial Day is a day of ceremony and speeches. Throughout America today we honor the dead of our wars. Whatever you think about Ronald Reagan, they called him the great communicator for a reason. The unknown soldier who is returned to us today and whom we later rest to symbolic of all our missing sons. This is him in 1984 during a military funeral at the Tomb of the Unknown Soldier at Arlington National Cemetery. On that memorial day, Reagan was eulogizing the remains of an unidentified servicemember
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。美国同胞们，阵亡将士纪念日是一个充满仪式和演讲的日子。今天，全美各地都在缅怀我们战争中的逝者。无论你对罗纳德·里根有何看法，人们称他为“伟大的沟通者”是有原因的。今天归还给我们的这位无名战士，以及我们随后安葬的这位战士，象征着我们所有失踪的子弟。这是1984年他在阿灵顿国家公墓无名战士墓举行的军事葬礼上的情景。在那个阵亡将士纪念日，里根正在为一位身份不明的军人遗骸致悼词。
from the Vietnam War. The remains would be entombed alongside three other unknown service members from World War I and II and the Korean War. It was a big event. That's our own Joe Rosenberg. A horse-drawn carriage brought the casket to the tomb past 250,000 onlookers, including hundreds of veterans who emerged out of the crowd to walk behind the remains on their way to Arlington.
来自越南战争。这些遗骸将被安葬在另外三位分别来自第一次世界大战、第二次世界大战和朝鲜战争的无名军人身旁。那是一场盛大的活动。那是我们的乔·罗森伯格。一辆马车拉着灵柩经过25万名围观者前往墓地，其中包括数百名从人群中走出来，跟随遗骸前往阿灵顿的退伍军人。
The most powerful part though, as when Reagan talks about who this unknown soldier might have been. Did he play on some street in a great American city? Or did he work with the side his father on a farm out in America's heartland? Did he marry? Did he have children? Did he look expectantly to return to a bride? We'll never know the answers to these questions about his life. As Reagan spoke, etched on the side of the tomb itself with words, known but to God.
然而，最震撼的部分是里根谈到这位无名战士可能是什么样的人时。他是否曾在美利坚伟大城市的某条街道上玩耍？或者他是否曾在美利坚腹地的农场里与父亲并肩劳作？他结婚了吗？他有孩子吗？他是否满怀期待地盼望着回到新娘身边？关于他的人生，我们永远无法得知这些问题的答案。当里根演讲时，墓碑侧面刻着这样的话：“唯有上帝知晓。”
It's all really moving, even knowing what we know now. Just that, although the person being buried that day might have been unknown to the public, a lot about his identity actually was known. The government likely even knew that he had a family who would like to have his body back, but they buried him anyway. How to honor unidentified remains has always been one of the great conundrums of war. The Romans were fond of honoring them with an empty sarcophagus. After the Civil War, the Union buried 2,111 soldiers in a mass grave in Arlington that they purposefully built on top of Robert E. Lee's Rose Garden. It wasn't until the
这一切真的很感人，即使我们现在已经知道了真相。那就是，尽管那天被安葬的人在公众眼中可能是无名的，但关于他的身份，其实有很多是已知的。政府甚至很可能知道他有家人希望领回他的遗体，但他们还是把他安葬了。如何纪念身份不明的遗骸一直是战争的一大难题。罗马人喜欢用空石棺来纪念他们。南北战争后，联邦军在阿灵顿的一个万人坑里埋葬了2111名士兵，他们特意将墓地建在罗伯特·E·李的玫瑰园之上。直到
20th century that it occurred to anyone to bury a single unknown soldier in a public setting. This sort of memorialization came about from World War One. This is Robert Poole. He's a former executive editor for National Geographic, who wrote a book about Arlington called On Hallowed Ground. And he says World War One ushered in an era of total war and mass participation in which the combatants on both sides were mostly ordinary citizens. Anonymous every man's, often rendered literally anonymous,
20世纪，才有人想到在公共场合安葬一名无名战士。这种纪念方式源于第一次世界大战。这是罗伯特·普尔。他是《国家地理》的前执行编辑，曾写过一本关于阿灵顿的书，名为《神圣的土地》。他说，第一次世界大战开启了一个全面战争和全民参与的时代，双方的参战者大多是普通公民。匿名的普通人，往往在字面上也变得匿名，
amidst the violence of the Western Front. Everything about the war, not only the numbers, but the nature of it, was dehumanizing. Nobody who went through that war was ever the same again. And there was a British chaplain who was in the worst of the fighting on the front lines named David Ralton. Ralton would spend his nights conducting funeral services over the remains of soldiers ripped apart by shell fire, often burying them on the spot, sometimes unmask and the giant
在西线的暴力之中。关于这场战争的一切，不仅是数字，还有它的本质，都是非人化的。任何经历过那场战争的人都再也回不到从前了。当时有一位英国随军牧师，他身处前线最激烈的战斗中，名叫大卫·雷尔顿。雷尔顿会在夜晚为那些被炮火炸得粉碎的士兵遗骸举行葬礼，通常就地掩埋，有时是在炮弹留下的巨大
craters the shells had left behind. And while he was there, he thought about how terrible it was that there were these people who were essentially forgotten buried in their graves and nobody would ever remember them, and that there should be something better than that for them. And it was around this time that David Rilton came across a temporary grave, a few miles behind the front, marked by a cross bearing the name of a regiment and the words, an unknown British soldier. And he realized, if you had a mass grave with 2,000 people in it, then it's a mass grave with 2,000 people in it.
弹坑里。当他在那里时，他想到这些人被遗忘在坟墓里，没有人会记得他们，这太可怕了，应该为他们做点更好的事情。就在那时，大卫·雷尔顿偶然发现了一个临时坟墓，位于前线几英里后方，上面立着一个十字架，写着一个团的名字和“一名英国无名战士”的字样。他意识到，如果你有一个埋着2000人的万人坑，那它就只是一个埋着2000人的万人坑。
It's not an individual who had a life. Something about having a particular person makes it more real, more human. After the war, Railton advocated for a grave bearing the body of a single soldier to bring the impossibly large tragedy down to a human scale. The soldiers in an imiti would allow each person who came to the grave to project whatever it was most important to them onto the mystery. It didn't matter if you wanted to honor all those who served, or merely those who died, those who volunteered, or those who were drafted, or even whether you were for the war or against it. Everyone was free to mourn in their own way."
它不是一个拥有过人生的个体。拥有一个具体的人会让它变得更真实、更人性化。战后，雷尔顿提倡建立一个安葬单名士兵遗体的坟墓，将那庞大到无法想象的悲剧缩小到人类可以感知的尺度。这个无名战士的坟墓将允许每一个来到墓前的人，将他们认为最重要的事情投射到这个谜团上。无论你是想纪念所有服役的人，还是仅仅纪念那些牺牲的人，是纪念那些志愿参军的人，还是那些被征召的人，甚至无论你是支持战争还是反对战争，这都不重要。每个人都可以自由地以自己的方式哀悼。
And sure enough, when Britain dedicated the grave of an unknown warrior in Westminster Abbey in 1920, it was an overnight success. The dedication alone attracted so many mourners, the line for viewing lasted 10 days. And Britain's unknown warrior wasn't the only one. Britain, France, Romania, Italy, everybody at the same time jumped on this idea. Over 50 countries would end up building similar memorials. in part because the formula was so easy to follow. All you needed was the body of a single unknown soldier. The American memorial is especially beautiful.
果然，当英国于1920年在威斯敏斯特教堂安葬无名战士墓时，它一夜之间就成功了。仅凭这次安葬仪式就吸引了如此多的哀悼者，排队瞻仰的队伍持续了10天。英国的无名战士并不是唯一的。英国、法国、罗马尼亚、意大利，每个人都在同一时间采纳了这个想法。最终有50多个国家建造了类似的纪念碑。部分原因是这个模式太容易效仿了。你只需要一具无名战士的遗体。美国的纪念碑特别漂亮。
It sits at the top of a hill that overlooks the rest of Arlington Cemetery. In starting in 1937, it has been watched over day and night without a single interruption by a lone guard forever marching back and forth in front of the tomb. No one knows which service the remains are from, so instead of soldier or sailor or marine, they're simply referred to as the unknown. In fact, anything that narrows the scope of who this person could be, including where exactly they were found, is purposefully withheld from the public in order to make sure that they represent everyone who fought.
它坐落在一座俯瞰阿灵顿公墓其余部分的山顶上。从1937年开始，它日夜受到一名孤独卫兵的守护，没有一刻中断，卫兵永远在墓前走来走去。没有人知道这些遗骸来自哪个军种，所以他们不被称为士兵、水手或海军陆战队员，而仅仅被称为“无名者”。事实上，任何缩小此人身份范围的信息，包括他们具体是在哪里被发现的，都被故意向公众隐瞒，以确保他们代表所有参战的人。
The tomb has become one of the Washington, D.C. areas biggest tourist attractions. But in 1956, we made one small seemingly innocent change to the formula of the unknown that would end up proving tricky. We began adding a new set of unidentified remains for every subsequent war. World War II, Korea, and eventually Vietnam. Each war would get their own unknown. Which made sense, there were lots of unknowns to choose from.
这座墓已成为华盛顿特区最大的旅游景点之一。但在1956年，我们对“无名者”的模式做了一个小小的、看似无害的改动，结果证明这很棘手。我们开始为随后的每一场战争增加一套新的身份不明遗骸。第二次世界大战、朝鲜战争，最终是越南战争。每一场战争都有自己的无名战士。这说得通，因为有很多无名者可供选择。
At least at first. In World War I, there were something like 1,648 unknowns. World War II, the unknowns were 8,526. A Korean War, 848. And then the last war in which we had an unknown Vietnam. 4. Thanks to improved battlefield evacuation tactics, the Vietnam War produced only four sets of unidentified remains that could potentially go into the tomb. And then, as more information about those remains was discovered, it was down to three,
至少起初是这样。在第一次世界大战中，大约有1648名无名者。第二次世界大战中，无名者有8526人。朝鲜战争有848人。然后是我们有无名者的最后一场战争——越南战争。4人。得益于战场撤离战术的改进，越南战争只产生了四具可能进入墓地的身份不明遗骸。然后，随着关于这些遗骸的更多信息被发现，数字降到了三个，
then down to two, then down to one. One set of remains for all of Vietnam, who was unknown. That single set of remains, the one Reagan eulogized in that movie in Ceremony in 1984, in which was presented to the public as the unknown soldier was referred to internally as X26. But his actual name was Michael Blassie. There's not supposed to be favorites in families, right? This is Patricia Blassie. But the first born just has something about them. Michael Blassie was Patricia's oldest brother.
然后降到两个，最后降到一个。整个越南战争只有一套遗骸是无名的。那套遗骸，就是里根在1984年的仪式上致悼词的那一位，被作为无名战士呈现给公众，在内部被称为X26。但他的真实名字是迈克尔·布拉西。家庭里不应该有偏爱，对吧？这是帕特里夏·布拉西。但长子总是有一些特别之处。迈克尔·布拉西是帕特里夏的大哥。
He was the oldest of five actually in the Blassie family. So growing up in St. Louis in the 1960s and 70s, she looked up to him. He was actually very good at anything that he did. Patricia says that Michael was constantly bouncing between activities, mastering each one before moving on to the next. School, music, sports. You know, I think he could have done whatever he wanted to, but then he received an appointment to the Air Force, and he fell in love with flying at the Academy. At flight school, Michael was assigned to fly a ground attack aircraft known as the A37, dubbed the Dragonfly or sometimes the Super Tweet.
他实际上是布拉西家五个孩子中的老大。所以20世纪60年代和70年代在圣路易斯长大时，她很崇拜他。他实际上非常擅长他所做的任何事情。帕特里夏说，迈克尔总是穿梭于各种活动之间，在转向下一项之前精通每一项。学校、音乐、体育。你知道，我想他本可以做任何他想做的事，但他收到了空军学院的录取通知，并在学院里爱上了飞行。在飞行学校，迈克尔被分配驾驶一种被称为A-37的地面攻击机，绰号“蜻蜓”或有时被称为“超级推特”。
It was designed to fly low over its target. Pilots loved it because that closer the ground, with the landscape rushing by, the sense of flight, speed, of combat was heightened. To the uninitiated, of course, all these things made flying the A-37 downright terrifying. But I don't remember Michael ever saying anything about being afraid of it. And so once he graduated, it was off to pilot training. Then from there, it was off to survival training. And from there, it was off to Vietnam. And I remember seeing him get on the aircraft in St. Louis. And I remember him looking back and waving to us with that beautiful smile. And I just remember thinking, oh, we'll see him again.
它的设计目的是在目标上方低空飞行。飞行员们喜欢它，因为离地面越近，随着风景飞速掠过，那种飞行、速度和战斗的感觉就越强烈。当然，对于外行来说，所有这些都让驾驶A-37变得非常可怕。但我不记得迈克尔说过任何关于害怕它的事。所以他毕业后，就去参加飞行训练了。然后从那里，他去参加了生存训练。再从那里，他去了越南。我记得看到他在圣路易斯登上飞机。我记得他回头看着我们，带着那美丽的微笑挥手。我只记得当时想，哦，我们会再见到他的。
I think we all did. By 1972, when Michael Blassie was deployed, America's military presence in Southeast Asia was shrinking rapidly. There were fewer than 25,000 U.S. servicemen left in Vietnam, as opposed to over 500,000 who had been deployed by the late 1960s. The war was, in effect, winding down, but it was still dangerous, and there was still a lot of combat going on. This is Bill Thomas. He's a reporter who wrote about Michael Blassy
我想我们都这么想。到1972年迈克尔·布拉西被部署时，美国在东南亚的军事存在正在迅速缩减。留在越南的美军不到25000人，而60年代末部署的人数超过50万。战争实际上正在结束，但它仍然很危险，而且战斗依然激烈。这是比尔·托马斯。他是一位报道过迈克尔·布拉西的记者
for the Washington Post, and he says that the American servicemen who remained behind were stretched then. They had to do a lot with a little. And that meant Michael was going to see a lot of combat. He arrived in Vietnam in January of 72. And by May of 1972? He had flown something like 130 missions. So virtually almost every day, he had at least one combat, sometimes two combat missions. So virtually almost every day, he had at least one combat, sometimes two combat
为《华盛顿邮报》撰稿，他说留在后面的美军当时捉襟见肘。他们必须以少做多。这意味着迈克尔将经历很多战斗。他于72年1月抵达越南。到1972年5月？他已经执行了大约130次任务。所以几乎每天，他至少有一次战斗，有时是两次战斗任务。所以几乎每天，他至少有一次战斗，有时是两次战斗
missions. The A37 that Michael flew had a good record up to that point in Vietnam, only if you had gotten hit. But when they were hit, things could get ugly fast. Because it could take all kinds of fire, I mean you're flying 400 feet in the air and you get hit, you're not going to be able to parachute out of the plane. So that made it very dangerous. Michael would always take off in land from a protected airbase near Saigon,
任务。迈克尔驾驶的A-37在越南之前的记录很好，只有少数被击中。但当他们被击中时，情况会迅速恶化。因为它可以承受各种火力，我的意思是你在400英尺的空中飞行，如果你被击中，你将无法跳伞逃生。所以这使它非常危险。迈克尔总是从西贡附近的一个受保护的空军基地起飞和降落，
but his missions had him flying over a lot of dangerous places. And the most dangerous was arguably a town in South Vietnam called An Locke. In 1972, An Locke was occupied by the South Vietnamese military, along with a handful of American advisors, but it was under siege by an invading North Vietnamese army. The siege lasted a very, very long time. It went on for months. And I encountered a guy who was in Ann Locke, Chris Calhoun.
但他的任务让他飞越了许多危险的地方。最危险的可以说是南越的一个小镇，叫安禄。1972年，安禄被南越军队占领，还有少数美国顾问，但它正受到入侵的北越军队的围困。围困持续了非常非常长的时间。持续了几个月。我遇到了一个在安禄的人，克里斯·卡尔霍恩。
And he said he described it as a scene out of apocalypse now. The city of Ann Locke was totally totally leveled it looked like Hiroshima. This is Chris Calhoun. He was stationed in Anlock as an army ranger during the majority of the siege, and he often resorted to analogies as a way of explaining just how awful it was there. At one point he described the South Vietnamese wounded with their meager medical support, as looking like something out of the Civil War. Anlock was completely cut off from the rest of the world.
他说他将其描述为《现代启示录》中的场景。安禄市被彻底夷为平地，看起来像广岛。这是克里斯·卡尔霍恩。他在围困期间的大部分时间里作为陆军游骑兵驻扎在安禄，他经常使用类比来解释那里有多糟糕。有一次，他描述南越伤员在医疗支持匮乏的情况下，看起来就像南北战争中的场景。安禄与世界其他地方完全隔绝了。
We got food and ammunition by parachute drop every day. We were under constant shell fire. Chris's duty in the midst of all this chaos was to call in air strikes. And it was Michael Blasie's quadrant that was providing the air support. They were flying bombing runs over and lock nearly every day. Michael and Chris never actually spoke one-on-one. Their time there didn't quite overlap. But Chris did get to know a lot of Michael's squadron mates really well.
我们每天通过降落伞空投获得食物和弹药。我们处于不断的炮火之下。克里斯在这一切混乱中的职责是呼叫空袭。而提供空中支援的正是迈克尔·布拉西的中队。他们几乎每天都在安禄上空进行轰炸。迈克尔和克里斯从未真正一对一地交谈过。他们在那里的时候并没有完全重叠。但克里斯确实非常了解迈克尔的许多中队战友。
And we would talk on a radio. They'd read me stars and stripes. Stars and stripes is the US military's independently run daily paper. Why would they read me stars and stripes. Stars and stripes is the US military's independently run daily paper. Why would they read you stars and stripes? Well, it was my only contact with the outside world. But in Anlock, they would be over us almost 24 hours a day. And they kept the North Vietnamese off our back. So these were people who I owed my life to.
我们会通过无线电交谈。他们会给我读《星条旗报》。《星条旗报》是美军独立运营的日报。他们为什么要给你读《星条旗报》？嗯，这是我与外界唯一的联系。但在安禄，他们几乎24小时都在我们上空。他们让北越军队远离我们。所以这些人是我欠下性命的人。
And it was on one of these bombing runs, keeping the North Vietnamese off their backs, that Michael Blassy flew his 130 second in final mission. We'll never know exactly what happened on May 11, 1972. Witnesses recall that day's fighting as being particularly intense and chaotic. So a lot of what we do know comes from Blassy's commanding officer, who was flying in a plane alongside Blassie's. And he said, the thing he remembered most of all was how bright everything was. The sky would have been filled with various planes and helicopters, each going after a separate target, but also tracer rounds being fired from multiple enemy aircraft guns. And they were taking ground fire the whole time,
就在其中一次轰炸任务中，为了让北越军队远离他们，迈克尔·布拉西执行了他的第132次也是最后一次任务。我们永远不会确切知道1972年5月11日发生了什么。目击者回忆说，那天的战斗特别激烈和混乱。所以我们所知道的很多信息来自布拉西的长官，他当时驾驶着一架飞机在布拉西的飞机旁边。他说，他记得最清楚的是一切是多么明亮。天空中充满了各种飞机和直升机，每一架都在追逐不同的目标，但也有来自多架敌方高射炮的曳光弹。他们一直受到地面火力的攻击，
but because they were flying into the sun, they couldn't see where it was coming from. So this just added to the confusion of the battle. And somewhere in the midst of the blinding sun and the chaos and confusion, Michael's plane was hit by ground fire. And remember, Michael's plane was designed to fly low. When he got hit, he was no more than 500 feet above the ground.
但因为他们是迎着太阳飞行，他们看不出火力来自哪里。这增加了战斗的混乱。在耀眼的阳光、混乱和困惑中，迈克尔的飞机被地面火力击中了。记住，迈克尔的飞机设计是低空飞行的。当他被击中时，他离地面不超过500英尺。
And he had lost control of the plane. Blessy's plane began streaming fuel, inverted, and then disappeared into the jungle below. And there was no distress signal, which indicates that the pilot had probably been killed instantly. Michael's plane had crashed deep in North Vietnamese held territory. A helicopter team tried to get to the crash site, but due to heavy enemy fire, they'd leave after just a few minutes, empty handed. After that, there didn't seem to be any way to get to
他失去了对飞机的控制。布拉西的飞机开始漏油，倒转，然后消失在下方的丛林中。没有发出求救信号，这表明飞行员可能已经当场死亡。迈克尔的飞机坠毁在北越控制区的深处。一支直升机小组试图到达坠机地点，但由于敌方火力猛烈，他们几分钟后就空手而归了。在那之后，似乎没有任何办法到达
the site or find out exactly what had happened. Michael Blassy was declared missing in action and presumed dead. The Blassy family was informed that Michael's body would not be coming home. But with, I don't, it's the strangest thing that when there is no body, there is no gathering. When Michael died, it wasn't the first time Patricia had to deal with the loss of a close family member. Both her parents came from big families, lots of aunts and uncles, lots of funerals. And she says that anytime someone passed away, they processed it by gathering together at the funeral
现场或查明到底发生了什么。迈克尔·布拉西被宣布在行动中失踪，并被推定死亡。布拉西一家被告知迈克尔的遗体不会回家了。但是，我不知道，最奇怪的事情是，当没有遗体时，就没有聚会。迈克尔去世时，这并不是帕特里夏第一次面对亲人的离世。她的父母都来自大家庭，有很多姑姑和叔叔，有很多葬礼。她说，每当有人去世，他们处理的方式就是聚集在葬礼上，
and just talking about the person's life, who they were, how much everyone missed them. But this time, without a body to place beneath the tombstone, the family opted not to have a funeral. I mean, there was a memorial gathering, but it still wasn't the same. We didn't talk about it. Everyone just was, I remember it's just like quiet. And then it was just like, well, we'll go on with our lives and try to be normal. Well, it wasn't normal.
谈论那个人的生活，他们是谁，每个人有多想念他们。但这一次，没有遗体放在墓碑下，家人选择不举行葬礼。我的意思是，有一个追悼会，但仍然不一样。我们没有谈论它。每个人都只是，我记得就像安静一样。然后就像，好吧，我们将继续我们的生活，努力变得正常。嗯，这并不正常。
Patricia says that Michael's death, or rather the not talking about Michael's death, ended up putting a strain on her parents' marriage. They later separated, and Patricia joined the Air Force, eventually attaining the rank of Colonel. Life in other words, went on, even as the topic of Michael sat undiscussed and unfinished. It was just sort of put on over on a shelf, this thing that we didn't get to deal with. And it didn't resurrect itself until 26 years later
帕特里夏说，迈克尔的死，或者更确切地说，不谈论迈克尔的死，最终给她父母的婚姻带来了压力。他们后来分居了，帕特里夏加入了空军，最终获得了上校军衔。换句话说，生活继续了，即使关于迈克尔的话题一直未被讨论且未了结。它就像被放在架子上一样，是我们没有机会处理的事情。直到26年后它才重新浮出水面，
after he was killed. We realized where he was. In 1994, more than two decades after Michael had been killed, both Patricia and her mother received a phone call from a complete stranger. And he said, I'm Ted Sampley, and I am a former Green Beret who has served in Vietnam. Ted Sampley has since passed away, but back then he was sort of this minor celebrity, championed the cause of Vietnam POWs and MIAs.
在他去世后。我们意识到他在哪里。1994年，在迈克尔去世二十多年后，帕特里夏和她的母亲接到了一个陌生人的电话。他说，我是泰德·桑普利，我是一名曾在越南服役的前绿色贝雷帽队员。泰德·桑普利后来去世了，但在当时他算是一个小名人，支持越南战俘和失踪人员的事业。
He was convinced the government wasn't telling veterans everything it knew. And he was calling Patricia without landish theory about Michael's death. I mean, there wasn't anything in his voice that was like angry or, you know, he would just matter a fact. But he said, I started researching who was shot down on May 11th, 1972. And, you know, what was found with them, and would that be on a fighter aircraft? His evidence was circumstantial,
他确信政府没有告诉退伍军人它所知道的一切。他打电话给帕特里夏，提出了关于迈克尔之死的离奇理论。我的意思是，他的声音里没有任何愤怒，你知道，他只是就事论事。但他说，我开始研究1972年5月11日谁被击落了，你知道，在他们身上发现了什么，那会是在战斗机上吗？他的证据是间接的，
and his logic was long-winded. But he said, I believe your brothers in the tomb of the unknowns. But the body from Vietnam that President Reagan had buried with pomp and ceremony in 1984 wasn't unknown at all. That it wasn't fact, Michael.
他的逻辑很冗长。但他确实说，我相信你的兄弟在无名战士墓里。但里根总统在1984年以盛大的仪式安葬的来自越南的遗骸根本不是无名的。事实上，那就是迈克尔。
At first, Patricia didn't know what to make of any of this. As far as she knew, Michael's body had never even been recovered. And remember, she herself was in the Air Force. So after getting off the phone with Sampley, she called up the Air Force casualty office and asked, could this be true? Could Michael B in the tomb of the unknown soldier? And they said by no means is there anything to substantiate that your brother's in the tomb? And I said, well, you know what? Thank you very much because that is the craziest story that I could ever imagine that a known soldier was in the tomb of the end-nones. I mean, you know, I don't know. That's the crazy. It's just, it just didn't make sense.
起初，帕特里夏不知道该怎么看待这一切。据她所知，迈克尔的遗体甚至从未被找回。记住，她自己就在空军。所以和桑普利通完电话后，她给空军伤亡办公室打了电话，问，这可能是真的吗？迈克尔可能在无名战士墓里吗？他们说，绝对没有任何证据证明你的兄弟在墓里。我说，好吧，你知道吗？非常感谢，因为这是我能想象到的最疯狂的故事，一个已知的士兵在无名战士墓里。我的意思是，你知道，我不知道。这太疯狂了。这根本说不通。
I thought this is the best example of internet conspiracy garbage I've seen to date. This is Vince Gonzalez. He was a young reporter at CBS Denver when he accidentally came across a post Ted Sampley had made on the internet about his theory that Michael Blassy had been buried in the two of the unknowns. This was in 1997, three years after the phone call with Patricia. And he says, yeah, of course, at first he totally dismissed it. And I thought, I'm going to print it out, I'm going to show it to college classes when I visit and say, this is why we say don't believe everything you read on the internet. And I did that.
我想这是我迄今为止见过的互联网阴谋论垃圾的最佳例子。这是文斯·冈萨雷斯。他是CBS丹佛台的一名年轻记者，当时他偶然发现泰德·桑普利在互联网上发布的一篇关于迈克尔·布拉西被安葬在无名战士墓的理论的帖子。那是在1997年，距离与帕特里夏通电话已经三年了。他说，是的，当然，起初他完全不屑一顾。我想，我要把它打印出来，当我访问大学课堂时展示给学生看，并说，这就是为什么我们说不要相信你在互联网上读到的所有东西。我确实那样做了。
I printed it out, had it on my desk at CBS, and then one evening I sat down and started reading it, and I thought, well, maybe I should check this out. Sampley had no direct evidence proving that Michael Blossy was in the tomb, but that didn't make him wrong. Whatever was known about the remains of the Vietnam unknown had never been revealed. It was all part of the effort to make sure that the unknown could represent everyone who ever fought in the war. But Sampley had come across some second-hand accounts suggesting that America's only set of unknown remains from Vietnam had been recovered from an aircraft that had been shot down in 1972.
我把它打印出来，放在CBS的办公桌上，然后一天晚上我坐下来开始阅读它，我想，也许我应该查查这件事。桑普利没有直接证据证明迈克尔·布拉西在墓里，但这并不意味着他是错的。关于越南无名者遗骸的任何已知信息从未被披露过。这一切都是为了确保无名者能够代表所有在战争中战斗过的人。但桑普利偶然发现了一些二手资料，暗示美国唯一一套来自越南的无名遗骸是从1972年被击落的飞机上找回的。
And he had only been able to find one missing plane that fully matched the description. Michael Blassies. What still made it hard to believe was that the government was not supposed to bury anyone in the tomb. If there was a chance he could be identified like this. So Vince called a few sources in the military, not asking any hard questions, just wondering,
他只找到了唯一一架完全符合描述的失踪飞机。迈克尔·布拉西的。仍然让人难以置信的是，政府不应该在墓里安葬任何人。如果他有可能像这样被识别出来的话。所以文斯给军队里的几个消息来源打了电话，没有问任何尖锐的问题，只是想知道，
almost kind of embarrassed. Could the government possibly bury a known person in the tomb of the unknowns and not tell anyone? One conversation in particular told me there was an attitude within some parts of the military that might allow something like this to happen. I called up a researcher in the Pentagon and I tried to talk really around the issue.
几乎有点尴尬。政府是否可能在无名战士墓中安葬一个已知身份的人而不告诉任何人？特别是其中一次谈话告诉我，军队内部存在一种态度，可能会导致这样的事情发生。我给五角大楼的一位研究员打了电话，我试图绕着这个问题谈。
I didn't want to let them know what I was working on, but I finally said, what if you could figure out who this was? What if we could go in and identify this person and give them back to his family? And his response was, oh, that would never happen. And I said, but that would be the truth. And he said, well, the truth doesn't matter.
我不想让他们知道我在做什么，但我最终说，如果你能弄清楚这是谁呢？如果我们能进去识别这个人并把他还给他的家人呢？他的回答是，哦，那永远不会发生。我说，但那是真相。他说，嗯，真相并不重要。
He's not a human being anymore. He's a symbol in America's most sacred military shrine, and we would never let that happen. So I wrote down the truth doesn't matter on a posted note, stuck it to my computer console, and I thought, if there's a chance, you could figure out who this is and give him back to his family, you should do it. Vince began filing for your requests, trying to get his hands on any government document he could about Michael Blassie.
他不再是一个人了。他是美国最神圣的军事圣地里的一个象征，我们永远不会让那种事发生。所以我把“真相并不重要”写在便利贴上，贴在我的电脑控制台上，我想，如果有机会能弄清楚这是谁并把他还给他的家人，你就应该去做。文斯开始提交信息自由法案请求，试图获取他能找到的任何关于迈克尔·布拉西的政府文件。
But there were things I wanted that only family members could get, where you needed an affidavit. So that was when I reached out to the glassy family. Vince got in touch with Patricia and laid out his case. Fact by fact, pattern by pattern. And Vince and I started talking and I called my mom and I said, you know what? It's somebody. And if it's Michael, you know, we need to pursue it. Which eventually gave Vince the leeway to file yet another foyer request. Nothing special,
但有些东西我想要，只有家庭成员才能得到，你需要一份宣誓书。所以那时我联系了布拉西一家。文斯联系了帕特里夏，并陈述了他的理由。事实对事实，模式对模式。文斯和我开始交谈，我给妈妈打了电话，我说，你知道吗？这是某个人。如果那是迈克尔，你知道，我们需要追查它。这最终给了文斯提交另一个信息自由法案请求的余地。没什么特别的，
just some documents related to Michael Blassy from an Air Force base in Texas. Not mentioning the tomb, not mentioning the unknown soldier, just asking for anything with Michael Blassy's name in it. And I got back this really thick envelope, a padded envelope, which is more than I think I'd gotten back from any other request. And I was actually back in Denver at that point sitting in the newsroom and I opened it up and I was paging through it, paging after paging, going, oh my god, this is it. Because this wasn't just some small file containing a good lead or a tantalizing clue. These were military documents showing the entire unknown soldier selection process.
只是一些与迈克尔·布拉西有关的文件，来自德克萨斯州的一个空军基地。没有提到墓地，没有提到无名战士，只是要求任何带有迈克尔·布拉西名字的东西。我收到了一个非常厚的信封，一个带衬垫的信封，这比我想象中从任何其他请求中得到的都要多。当时我实际上回到了丹佛，坐在新闻编辑室里，我打开它，一页一页地翻看，心想，天哪，就是这个。因为这不仅仅是一些包含好线索或诱人暗示的小文件。这些是显示整个无名战士选择过程的军事文件。
When combined with his earlier research, the documents Vince Gonzalez now held in his hands, painted a nearly complete picture of what the government knew regarding the identity of the unknown soldier, starting with something very important that they had known almost from the beginning. That Michael Blassey's remains had been recovered in Vietnam and that they'd been recovered by Chris Calhoun, the Army Ranger stationed in the unlock. You know, I don't really know exactly what went down, but I do know that everything pointed to me.
当与他早期的研究结合起来时，文斯·冈萨雷斯现在手中的文件描绘了一幅几乎完整的图景，关于政府对无名战士身份的了解，从他们几乎从一开始就知道的一件非常重要的事情开始。迈克尔·布拉西的遗骸是在越南找回的，而且是由驻扎在安禄的陆军游骑兵克里斯·卡尔霍恩找回的。你知道，我真的不知道到底发生了什么，但我确实知道一切都指向我。
Now remember Calhoun didn't know Blassie personally, but he was friends with a bunch of the other pilots in Michael Squadron. They were the guys reading the newspaper to Calhoun didn't know Blassy personally, but he was friends with a bunch of the other pilots in Michael Squadron. They were the guys reading the newspaper to Calhoun over the radio. And it was on one of those lonely nights, just chatting, that they started telling him about Michael. The only thing I knew was they asked me that one of their squadron mates had been shot down. They gave me the coordinates, and they wanted to know if we could get the body back. This was in October of 1972, over five months since Blassey's plane had disappeared into
现在记住，卡尔霍恩并不认识布拉西本人，但他和迈克尔中队的许多其他飞行员是朋友。他们是那些给卡尔霍恩读报纸的人。卡尔霍恩并不认识布拉西本人，但他和迈克尔中队的许多其他飞行员是朋友。他们是那些通过无线电给卡尔霍恩读报纸的人。就在那些孤独的夜晚，聊天时，他们开始告诉他关于迈克尔的事。我唯一知道的是，他们问我，他们中队的一个战友被击落了。他们给了我坐标，他们想知道我们是否能找回遗体。那是在1972年10月，距离布拉西的飞机消失在
the jungle. They knew they were asking a lot. So I think if that rapport wasn't there, then the request would have never come and I would have never acted on it. Christchurch the matter to his regimental commander, who assembled a special South Vietnamese patrol dressed up as the enemy. In North Vietnamese uniforms with North Vietnamese weapons and they went out in no man's land and they found the wreckage. And they brought back to me what was left of the remains of Michael Blassy in a black plastic bag. The remains did not consist of much, just six bones, but they also brought back other
丛林中已经过去了五个多月。他们知道他们要求很高。所以我认为如果那种融洽的关系不存在，那么请求就不会到来，我也永远不会采取行动。克里斯把这件事告诉了他的团长，团长组建了一支特别的南越巡逻队，打扮成敌人的样子。穿着北越军装，带着北越武器，他们进入了无人区，找到了残骸。他们带回了迈克尔·布拉西遗骸的残余部分，装在一个黑色塑料袋里。遗骸并不多，只有六块骨头，但他们也带回了其他
evidence. An uninflated life raft was serial numbers, a parachute, part of Michael's flight suit, and critically his wallet. And that was a good shape. Pictures of him, pictures of his family, pictures of his sister. There was no question. The remains were Michaels. Chris then handed the bag with everything in it
证据。一个未充气的救生筏，带有序列号，一个降落伞，迈克尔飞行服的一部分，以及至关重要的他的钱包。那东西保存完好。他的照片，他家人的照片，他姐姐的照片。毫无疑问。遗骸就是迈克尔的。克里斯随后把装有所有东西的袋子
off to the crew chief of the week's one outgoing helicopter. But he got the bag. The crew chief got the bag. And when you saw the remains, I go away in the chopper. I mean, what was your decision? Well, we were we were sending them home to his family. You know, we were doing what was right. And of course, those South Vietnamese risk their lives to, you know, get his body from that wreckage. Then he deserved to go home. After that, Chris had just assumed
交给了当周即将离开的直升机的机组长。但他拿到了袋子。机组长拿到了袋子。当你看到遗骸时，我乘直升机离开了。我的意思是，你的决定是什么？嗯，我们当时正要把他们送回他的家人身边。你知道，我们在做正确的事。当然，那些南越人冒着生命危险，你知道，从残骸中找回了他的遗体。那么他理应回家。在那之后，克里斯只是假设
that Michael's remains would be returning to his family. But according to Vince's documents, that's not what happened. The remains, along with the survival gear, would eventually arrive at the Army's Central Identification Laboratory in Hawaii. But not before the wallet, containing the ID that could link the bones to Blassy
迈克尔的遗骸会回到他的家人身边。但根据文斯的文件，事情并非如此。遗骸连同生存装备最终抵达了位于夏威夷的陆军中央鉴定实验室。但在那之前，钱包，包含可以把骨头与布拉西联系起来的身份证件，
went missing. Even though he knew about the missing wallet, the head of the lab, using now outdated techniques, determined that the remains did not match Michael Blassy's physical description. Instead, they were simply designated as BTB, believed to be Michael Blassy. Without a positive match due to army policy, the Blassie family could not even be told that any remains had been found. Meanwhile, pressure began to mount in the Pentagon
不见了。尽管他知道钱包丢失的事，实验室负责人使用现在过时的技术确定，遗骸与迈克尔·布拉西的身体描述不符。相反，他们被简单地指定为BTB，即“被认为是迈克尔·布拉西”。由于陆军政策，没有确切匹配，布拉西一家甚至不能被告知已经发现了任何遗骸。与此同时，五角大楼开始面临压力，
to place a veteran from Vietnam in the tomb of the unknown soldier. It was politics, but it was also patriotism. While there was a crass political angle to do this, to make nice with the Vietnam veterans, there was also a feeling of we need to get someone in that tomb so the nation can heal around this issue. But by the 1980s, there was only one set of unidentified remains left. The ones labeled believe to be Michael Blassy. So in 1980, the lab was ordered to strip their remains of their formal connection with Blassie and give them the anonymous designation X-26.
要将一名越南老兵安葬在无名战士墓中。这是政治，但也是爱国主义。虽然这样做有一个粗俗的政治角度，即与越南退伍军人搞好关系，但也有这样一种感觉：我们需要让某人进入那个墓地，这样国家才能围绕这个问题愈合。但到了20世纪80年代，只剩下一套身份不明的遗骸了。那些被标记为“被认为是迈克尔·布拉西”的遗骸。因此，在1980年，实验室被命令剥夺这些遗骸与布拉西的正式联系，并给他们匿名代号X-26。
And in 1984, with the Reagan administration eager to put someone on the tune before election day, they were told to prepare X-26 for burial. And I spoke with technicians at the Army lab later who said, we gave them every answer possible to say, don't do this. The technology is coming. This is not an unknown set of remains. The lab technicians told the Pentagon that new DNA-based technology was being developed that would allow the remains to be conclusively identified.
1984年，里根政府急于在选举日前将某人安葬在墓中，他们被告知准备X-26进行安葬。后来我与陆军实验室的技术人员交谈，他们说，我们给了他们所有可能的答案，说，不要这样做。技术正在进步。这不是一套无名遗骸。实验室技术人员告诉五角大楼，正在开发基于DNA的新技术，这将使遗骸能够被最终识别。
They also pointed to the artifacts, like the flight suit and the life raft, and a record of the missing wallet, all of which suggested that their remains were most likely glasses. But the push to put a Vietnam unknown in the tomb overrode that, and a general from the army was sent to tell them everybody better get the hell out of the way. And that's when Michael Blassie went into the tomb. I fell of Americans Memorial Day is a day of ceremonies and speeches. Throughout America today we honor the death of our wars. And it's when President Reagan, who may not have known that any of this had happened,
他们还指出了文物，如飞行服和救生筏，以及丢失钱包的记录，所有这些都表明遗骸很可能是布拉西的。但将越南无名者安葬在墓中的推动力压倒了这一点，陆军的一位将军被派去告诉他们，每个人最好都滚开。就在那时，迈克尔·布拉西进入了墓地。美国同胞们，阵亡将士纪念日是一个充满仪式和演讲的日子。今天，全美各地都在缅怀我们战争中的逝者。当里根总统，他可能不知道这一切已经发生，
gave a speech at a burial in Arlington invoking a powerful mystery. Did he marry? Did he have children? Did he look expectantly to return to a bride? We'll never know the answers to these questions about his life. The file that Vince discovered 13 years later in 1997 showed that there had never been any mystery at all. Armed with the documents, he teamed up with veteran CBS correspondent Eric Angberg. They talked to anyone they could find who was involved in the unknown selection process.
在阿灵顿的葬礼上发表了演讲，唤起了一个强大的谜团。他结婚了吗？他有孩子吗？他是否满怀期待地盼望着回到新娘身边？我们永远不会知道关于他人生这些问题的答案。文斯在13年后的1997年发现的文件显示，根本没有任何谜团。带着这些文件，他与资深CBS记者埃里克·恩伯格合作。他们与任何能找到的参与无名者选择过程的人交谈。
And when they felt they were ready, they presented their findings to Patricia Blassy. And I asked my mom to call a family meeting and we sat down and we looked at the documents together and we discussed, you know, what should we do? Patricia wanted to go public with Vince and CBS. Her older sister, Judy, if anything, was even more eager to blow the lid off the whole thing. But George, the youngest brother, Boked. Michael is buried in a place of honor, he pointed out. Maybe he could stay there and serve as the unknown for everyone else who's loved the ones that never come back.
当他们觉得准备好时，他们向帕特里夏·布拉西展示了他们的发现。我请我妈妈召开家庭会议，我们坐下来一起查看文件，讨论了，你知道，我们应该做什么？帕特里夏想和文斯以及CBS公开这件事。她的姐姐朱迪，如果说有什么不同的话，甚至更渴望揭开这一切。但乔治，最小的弟弟，表示反对。迈克尔被安葬在一个荣誉之地，他指出。也许他可以留在那儿，作为所有那些从未回家的亲人的无名者。
But the tiebreaker was Michael's mother, Jean. She's a very patient woman and she listened to all of the opinions of her children, her living children and waited until we were done with our banter or whatever. And she just looked at us and she said, I want to bring my son home. This is the CBS Evening News. Tonight, the results of an Ion America investigation lasting over half a year.
但打破僵局的是迈克尔的母亲，简。她是一位非常有耐心的女性，她听取了她所有孩子，她健在的孩子们的意见，并等到我们结束了我们的闲聊或其他什么。她只是看着我们说，我想带我的儿子回家。这是CBS晚间新闻。今晚，一项持续了半年多的“美国之声”调查的结果。
Is it possible the government knows the identity of a Vietnam war casualty buried at the tomb of the unknowns in Arlington National Cemetery, but deliberately kept its secret from the public and even his own family? A seven-month CBS News investigation has found evidence of a long-running cover-up. What followed wasn't just one story on the evening news. It was more like a blizzard of stories. There are significant new developments tonight in the exclusive story that CBS News first broke
政府是否可能知道安葬在阿灵顿国家公墓无名战士墓中的越南战争伤亡人员的身份，却故意向公众甚至他的家人隐瞒？一项为期七个月的CBS新闻调查发现了长期掩盖真相的证据。随之而来的不仅仅是晚间新闻中的一个故事。这更像是一场故事的暴风雪。今晚，CBS新闻首次报道的独家故事有重大新进展
on this broadcast in January. CBS's Vince Gonzalez uncovered new evidence and update tonight of our exclusive Ion America investigation. I think we did 15 or 18 pieces on this. It just was non-stop. And tonight, as Eric Ngberg tells us, there's more. Because CBS and the Blassy family didn't just want the world to know that Michael Blassy was in the tomb.
在这次广播中。CBS的文斯·冈萨雷斯发现了新的证据，今晚更新了我们独家的“美国之声”调查。我想我们对此做了15或18篇报道。这简直是没完没了。今晚，正如埃里克·恩伯格告诉我们的，还有更多。因为CBS和布拉西一家不仅想让世界知道迈克尔·布拉西在墓里。
They wanted the Pentagon to do something about it. Michael Blassy's sister Pat says the family wants the remains tested, even if by some chance they aren't identified as Michael. Now Congress wants to investigate. If it's Michael, we want to bring him home. At a certain point, they called us up and they said, you're killin' us. And day or two later, they announced the tomb would be open
他们想让五角大楼对此采取行动。迈克尔·布拉西的姐姐帕特说，家人希望对遗骸进行检测，即使万一他们没有被确认为迈克尔。现在国会想要调查。如果是迈克尔，我们想带他回家。在某个时刻，他们打电话给我们说，你们快把我们逼疯了。一两天后，他们宣布墓地将开放，
and the remains were going to be tested. On May 14, 1998, the Department of Defense disinterred the remains of the Vietnam veteran from the tomb of the unknown soldier. DNA samples were taken from Michael's mother Jane and his sister Judy, and tested against the remains. They were a match. And after the scientists were finished talking to my mother, we were wrapping things up because
遗骸将被检测。1998年5月14日，国防部将越南老兵的遗骸从无名战士墓中挖掘出来。从迈克尔的母亲简和他的姐姐朱迪那里提取了DNA样本，并与遗骸进行了比对。他们匹配上了。在科学家们和我的母亲谈完之后，我们正在结束这一切，因为
my mother had to sign some papers and things like that. And then all of a sudden a man walked up and said, well, when we opened the tomb to do the DNA test, Michael's artifacts were in the tomb with him. And what would you like us to do with them? The life raft and other items that had been found at the crash in 1972 had been the only physical evidence aside from the missing wallet that could have tied the remains to Michael Blassy. Whether it was to preserve the artifacts or to hide them,
我母亲不得不签署一些文件之类的东西。突然，一名男子走过来对我们说，我们在打开墓穴进行DNA测试时，迈克尔的遗物就在墓穴里和他在一起。你们想让我们怎么处理这些东西？1972年坠机现场发现的救生筏和其他物品，除了那个丢失的钱包外，是唯一能将遗骸与迈克尔·布拉西联系起来的实物证据。无论是为了保存这些遗物还是为了隐藏它们，
someone at the Army Lab in Hawaii had put them where no one would ever think to look in the casket with Michael. They had been sitting in the tomb underneath the guards and the crowds and the Arlington soil for 14 years. They were in a box. And so after we buried Michael in St. Louis, there was a reception and then once everyone left,
夏威夷陆军实验室的某个人把它们放在了没人会想到的地方——和迈克尔一起放在棺材里。它们在墓穴里，在卫兵、人群和阿灵顿的泥土下静静地躺了14年。它们被装在一个盒子里。所以，在我们把迈克尔安葬在圣路易斯之后，举行了招待会，等大家都离开后，
we stood around the table and my brother George opened up the box and started pulling out the life raft, portions of his parachute, portions of his flight suit. And I have him with me today. I keep him with me. But I was really glad to have them. Today, there is no body representing Vietnam at the tomb of the unknowns. And thanks to improved forensics, there will likely never be an unknown from Iraq, or Afghanistan, or any future war.
我们围在桌子旁，我哥哥乔打开了盒子，开始拿出救生筏、降落伞的一部分、飞行服的一部分。今天他和我在一起。我一直带着他。但我真的很高兴能拥有这些东西。今天，无名战士墓中已经没有代表越南战争的遗骸了。多亏了法医技术的进步，未来可能再也不会有来自伊拉克、阿富汗或任何未来战争的无名战士了。
The military is now in the process of using the DNA from the families of missing veterans to identify over 650 sets of unknown remains from the Korean War. It's conceivable that they could use the same techniques on the Korean unknown inside the tomb. The unknowns from World War I and World War II are safe for now, but in the era of 23 and me, well, let's just say anything's possible. If you go to Arlington today, the tomb of the unknowns is still there, minus the remains for Vietnam. The tourists still take pictures on their phones, and the guards still make
军方目前正在利用失踪退伍军人家属的DNA，来鉴定朝鲜战争中650多具无名遗骸。可以想象，他们也可以对墓中的朝鲜战争无名战士使用同样的技术。第一次世界大战和第二次世界大战的无名战士目前还很安全，但在“23 and me”基因检测时代，嗯，只能说一切皆有可能。如果你今天去阿灵顿，无名战士墓依然在那里，只是少了越南战争的遗骸。游客们依然用手机拍照，卫兵们依然进行着
their rounds in perfect silent precision. Day and night, even when no one is watching, and it really is beautiful. You should go see it. But the heyday of this unique form of remembrance has come to an end. Does that sadden you? Like, does it sadden you that there is no unknown for Vietnam anymore? I can't say that it saddens me. I can't say that it saddens me. I can't say that. I respect the tomb of the unknowns.
他们那完美而寂静的例行巡逻。日日夜夜，即使在没人注视的时候，那景象真的很美。你应该去看看。但这种独特的纪念形式的鼎盛时期已经结束了。这让你感到难过吗？比如，越南战争不再有无名战士，这让你感到难过吗？我不能说这让我难过。我不能说这让我难过。我不能那样说。我尊重无名战士墓。
But in order to have an unknown, they made one. They took Michael's name away from him to satisfy something I understand it was very important to our nation. But the first thing that you and I did when we met one another over the phone, hi, I'm Patricia or I'm Pat, hi, I'm Joe. A name is very, very important. Patricia still visits the tomb. She says she's not sure why she does it, but it means that she's gotten to know some of the guards. One of them once told her that their mission, guarding the unknowns, is never really over. But that in Michael's case, just this once, their mission was completed.
但为了有一个“无名者”，他们制造了一个。他们剥夺了迈克尔的名字，以满足我认为对我们国家非常重要的事情。但你我在电话里第一次见面时做的第一件事就是：嗨，我是帕特里夏，或者我是帕特；嗨，我是乔。名字是非常、非常重要的。帕特里夏仍然会去墓地。她说她不知道为什么要去，但这让她认识了一些卫兵。其中一人曾告诉她，他们守卫无名战士的使命永远不会真正结束。但在迈克尔的案例中，仅此一次，他们的使命完成了。
They were just looking out for him, until he could go home. Joe talks me through the very precise ceremony that has evolved at the tomb of the unknown after this. Okay, Roman. So when I was a little kid, my parents, and I think my grandparents who lived just outside of Washington, DC, they took me to Arlington Cemetery to see the tomb of the unknown soldier. And I remember it really well, and I have to say the reason I remember it so well, and the reason I became interested in the tomb again more recently, is not the mysterious soldier in the tomb projecting whatever you want onto his anonymity.
他们只是在守护他，直到他能回家。乔向我详细介绍了此后在无名战士墓演变出的非常精确的仪式。好的，罗曼。所以当我还是个小孩子的时候，我的父母，我想还有住在华盛顿特区郊外的祖父母，带我去了阿灵顿公墓看无名战士墓。我记得很清楚，我必须说我记得这么清楚的原因，以及我最近再次对这座墓产生兴趣的原因，并不是因为墓中那个神秘的士兵，让你对他那匿名性产生任何联想。
It's actually the guard. And it's not so much It's actually the guard. And it's not so much the idea of the guard keeping vigil, like this solemn duty, as much as it is what the guard is physically doing. And what they are doing most of the time is just taking 21 steps to the left, turning, stopping for 21 seconds, then turning and stopping
其实是卫兵。这不仅仅是关于卫兵守夜的想法，那种庄严的职责，更多的是关于卫兵在身体上所做的事情。他们大部分时间所做的只是向左走21步，转身，停顿21秒，然后转身，停顿
for another 21 seconds, then taking 21 steps to the right, then stopping again, turning again, stopping again, stepping again, over and over and over until there's a guard change every 30 minutes to an hour. That sounds very, very precise. Yeah, and actually, that's the thing. It's like, you say that, but you have no idea. Yeah. Let me sell you on this by just showing you a video of what this looks like.
再停顿21秒，然后向右走21步，然后再次停顿，再次转身，再次停顿，再次迈步，一遍又一遍，直到每30分钟到一个小时进行一次换岗。听起来非常、非常精确。是的，实际上，这就是重点。就像，你这么说，但你根本不知道。是的。让我给你展示一段视频，让你看看这是什么样子的，以此来说服你。
This is from a guard change. Oh, where's my Nice design touch. The stripes on the legs really sell the synchronization. So as regimented as I was imagining it, it is even more so. It is like the innards of a Swiss clock, the way that they move together and then they move in time is stunning. Yeah, no.
这是换岗仪式。哦，我的设计真不错。腿上的条纹确实让同步感显得很真实。所以，正如我所想象的那样严谨，它甚至更甚。他们移动的方式就像瑞士钟表的内部零件，他们一起移动，然后同步移动，真是令人惊叹。是的，没错。
And one of the things I kind of really appreciate it is just the way, like, if you have a Swiss clock that is kind of ticking away with precision, it hasn't this way of magnifying the silence around it. There's a kind of the silence around it. There's a kind of weird silence to it. And apparently, to get this right, they train and practice for months in a separate facility. Wow.
我真正欣赏的一点是，如果你有一个像瑞士钟表那样精确走时的东西，它有一种放大周围寂静的方式。有一种……周围有一种奇怪的寂静。显然，为了做到这一点，他们在一个独立的设施里训练和练习了几个月。哇。
And it's almost meditative. Like you said, like inside of the silence, when you hear the clicking of their shoes and their heels together, you do get this space that's created inside of it that's very meditative. The word that just instantly came to mind is like zen. You watch the marching back and forth and the guards, when they're doing it,
这几乎是冥想式的。就像你说的，在寂静之中，当你听到他们鞋子和脚后跟撞击的声音时，你确实会感受到一种在其中创造出来的空间，非常具有冥想感。脑海中立刻浮现出的词就是“禅”。你看着他们来回走动，卫兵们在做这些动作时，
they don't seem lost in the performance. Instead, at every step, they are totally present. They are completely aware of their surroundings. They are truly doing nothing but this Unless you start laughing. Oh It is requested that all visitors maintain an atmosphere of silence and respect at all times Holy moly I don't want to cross that guy at all
他们似乎并没有迷失在表演中。相反，在每一步中，他们都完全处于当下。他们完全意识到周围的环境。他们真的什么都没做，只是在做这件事……除非你开始笑。哦，要求所有游客在任何时候都保持安静和尊重的氛围。天哪，我一点也不想惹那个家伙。
No, it's really terrifying. It just bursts out of nowhere. This is what happens if you get too rowdy or you laugh at the tomb of the unknown. And there's more. There's this whole subgenre of YouTube videos of like Tomb Guards yelling at, yelling at visitors. Oh, good, they deserve it. Let's hear it. Let's hear it.
不，这真的很可怕。它突然爆发出来。如果你在无名战士墓太吵闹或者大笑，就会发生这种情况。而且还有更多。YouTube上有一个关于卫兵对游客大喊大叫的视频子类型。哦，太好了，他们活该。让我们听听。让我们听听。
So let's find another one. In your question, it all appears to it. Let's hear it. So like, let's find it. Let's find another one. They're questioning it all for you to remain behind the change of rail. As your question, it all visitors remain behind the change of rails. It's like, it's like, and like, but they can just vary it up. They can like vary their tone. They can switch up the words a little bit. I think it depends on the guard. It depends on there. Maybe they're mood that day.
所以让我们找另一个。在你的问题中，这一切都显现出来了。让我们听听。所以，让我们找找。让我们找另一个。他们质疑这一切，让你留在换岗栏杆后面。正如你的问题，所有游客都留在换岗栏杆后面。就像，就像，而且，他们可以改变它。他们可以改变他们的语气。他们可以稍微改变一下措辞。我认为这取决于卫兵。这取决于他们。也许是他们那天的心情。
Holy moly. So here's a here's a here's a more Kurt one. You'll be on the rail. Oh, I love it. I'm holding moly. So here's a mo- Kurt one. You're behind the rail. Oh, I love it. Just let them have it. And this is one where they reprimand some parents. Visitors must keep their children
天哪。所以这里有一个更生硬的。你得在栏杆后面。哦，我喜欢。天哪。所以这里有一个更生硬的。你得在栏杆后面。哦，我喜欢。就让他们那样吧。这是一个他们训斥一些家长的视频。游客必须让他们的孩子
behind the rail trains and rails. Thank you. Little Billy, yanked back real fast. That happened to me. So there's other videos where you see people trying to sneak in like kind of behind the rails, you get a view of them and then they're yelled at and then they just like, they freeze like chipmunks
待在栏杆后面。谢谢。小比利被猛地拉了回来。那也发生在我身上。所以还有其他视频，你看到人们试图偷偷溜到栏杆后面，你看到了他们，然后他们被大声呵斥，然后他们就像……他们像花栗鼠一样僵住了，
who have been like caught out in the open and then just like just bolted it, like it's terrifying. My favorite comment though is from a YouTube user who said, and I quote, when I was 10 years old, I made the mistake of sitting down during the changing of the guards, and I almost shat myself. Okay.
那些在空旷处被抓住，然后就像……直接逃跑了，这太可怕了。不过我最喜欢的评论来自一位YouTube用户，他说，引用一下：“当我10岁的时候，我犯了一个错误，在换岗时坐了下来，我差点吓尿了。”好的。
Does any other national monument have something like this, where there's this 24-7 ritual? Why in particular is it happening right here? Well, yeah, I mean, that's a good question, because the thing about the tomb is that like, the way it is now is not the way it always was. It evolved into all of this kind of pomp and ceremony and spectacle when it was first commemorating in 1921.
还有其他国家纪念碑有这样的东西吗，有这种24小时全天候的仪式？为什么特别是在这里发生？嗯，是的，我的意思是，这是一个好问题，因为关于这座墓的事情是，它现在的样子并不是它一直以来的样子。当它在1921年首次纪念时，它演变成了所有这种排场、仪式和奇观。
It was a big moment. I think it was the first nationwide radio address that the president ever gave was from the commemoration of the tomb of the unknown. But back then it was just kind of this low stone slab. Like there was no big edifice or anything like that. And it kind of became a second rate monument for a while. Like people would picnic there. And photographers would like, because it has a great view of you know of the surrounding area because it's up on this hill And photographers would actually kind of set up shop there and people would like pose on the tomb
那是一个伟大的时刻。我想这是总统发表的第一次全国广播讲话，就是在无名战士墓的纪念仪式上。但那时它只是一块低矮的石板。就像没有宏伟的建筑之类的东西。它有一段时间变成了一个二流的纪念碑。人们会在那里野餐。摄影师会因为那里视野很好，你知道，周围的区域，因为它在山上，摄影师实际上会在这里摆摊，人们会像在墓上摆姿势一样。
Almost like just kind of like a roadside attraction and people but apparently like veterans caught on to this and started complaining about it Because they saw that kind of people were just treating it. Yeah, like Entertainment and they were like kind of putting out their cigarettes on it, things like that. And so they kind of complained about it to Congress and eventually the government cobbled together the money to post a guard. And then starting in 1937, the guard was 24-7.
几乎就像一个路边景点，但显然退伍军人注意到了这一点，并开始抱怨。因为他们看到人们只是把它当作……是的，当作娱乐，他们会在上面熄灭香烟之类的东西。所以他们向国会投诉，最终政府凑钱雇了一名卫兵。然后从1937年开始，卫兵就是24小时全天候的了。
And I've seen competing records on this once some say since 1937, others say, since 1948, the guard has never left. Even for hurricanes, it's stayed there. Wow. And then the other thing that happened during that time is that they always intended for there to be like a more updated fancy tomb, but it just took them forever to get around to getting the funding.
我见过关于这个的相互矛盾的记录，有的说从1937年开始，有的说从1948年开始，卫兵从未离开过。即使是飓风期间，它也一直守在那里。哇。然后在那段时间发生的另一件事是，他们一直打算建一个更现代、更华丽的墓，但他们花了很长时间才筹集到资金。
But eventually they did, and so they built the kind of the giant sarcophagus in 1931. And for that, they went to this quarry in Colorado, actually, to ensure that they got the exact same marble as the Lincoln Memorial. And although it wasn't designed by these guys, it was sculpted, like the actual physical sculpting is by this like famous set of brothers called the Picker Really Brothers,
但最终他们做到了，所以在1931年建造了那个巨大的石棺。为此，他们实际上去了科罗拉多州的一个采石场，以确保他们得到与林肯纪念堂完全相同的白色大理石。虽然它不是由这些人设计的，但它是雕刻的，就像实际的物理雕刻是由一对著名的兄弟完成的，叫皮奇里利兄弟，
who were these Italian brothers, who sculpted like everything they sculpted the Lincoln Memorial. And my favorite is they sculpted the two lions in front of the New York City Public Library. Wow. And then, in 1956, that's when we started adding these further unknowns from World War II, Korea, et cetera. Yeah. So just built and built and built.
他们是意大利兄弟，雕刻了几乎所有东西，他们雕刻了林肯纪念堂。我最喜欢的是，他们雕刻了纽约公共图书馆门前的两只狮子。哇。然后，在1956年，我们开始增加来自第二次世界大战、朝鲜战争等的无名战士。是的。所以就是不断地建造、建造、再建造。
Into this more and more reverent place. It has the image of an almost timeless tradition when you see it like this, but I actually kind of enjoy the fact that this is something that was, you know, iterated upon and improved and, you know, given a little more weight over time. I doubly appreciate it, because I love when something's iterative in the direction of honing towards austerity and elegance, as opposed to iterative and feeling like cluttered. Getting more casual or something like that.
变成了一个越来越庄严的地方。当你这样看它时，它有一种近乎永恒的传统形象，但我实际上很喜欢这样一个事实，即这是一个经过迭代、改进，并且随着时间的推移被赋予了更多分量的事物。我加倍欣赏它，因为我喜欢那种朝着简洁和优雅方向迭代的事物，而不是那种感觉杂乱的迭代。变得更随意之类的。
It's a fascinating place, particularly because of this ceremony makes it all the more special. Have you ever had a chance to speak to one of the guards when you do in the reporting? I confess, I did not manage to reach a guard in time for this Coda. I had bigger face to fry, right? I had a story to make. Totally, totally. There was a 20-year mystery, so.
这是一个迷人的地方，特别是这种仪式让它变得更加特别。你在报道时有没有机会和其中一名卫兵交谈？我承认，我没能及时联系到卫兵来完成这个尾声。我有更重要的事情要做，对吧？我有一个故事要完成。完全是这样。这是一个20年的谜团，所以。
But I got the next best thing, which is I found that one of the guards did, of course, a Reddit asked me anything. That's what I said, yeah, it's next best thing. And so, of course, one of the things is like when you're a reporter and you see and ask me anything thread, you're like, you go through it, hoping someone's going to ask like the question you would ask. And the only question I wanted to ask is like, what is going through your head when you are marching back and forth, and that's particularly not during the change in the
但我得到了次好的东西，那就是我发现其中一名卫兵确实在Reddit上做了一个“问我任何事”。这就是我说的，是的，这是次好的东西。所以，当然，当你是一名记者，看到一个“问我任何事”的帖子时，你会浏览它，希望有人会问你想要问的问题。我唯一想问的问题是，当你来回走动时，你的脑子里在想什么，特别是不是在换岗期间，
guard, but just during the long 30 minutes, the long hour, marching back and forth during this like meditative state, right? And so finally, someone like asked this, right? And the guard responded, I wish I could say that while we were doing this job, we are just meditating. What it means to guard the unknowns, but we are human and we are on duty for long hours. So our minds do wander quite a bit, which just was so disappointing to read. Oh, but it's really human. You know, I know. I know, but here know, but here's the irony, which is like,
而是在漫长的30分钟、漫长的一小时里，在这种冥想状态下走来走去，对吧？所以最后，有人问了这个问题，对吧？卫兵回答说：“我希望我能说，当我们做这份工作时，我们只是在冥想。守卫无名战士意味着什么，但我们是人，我们长时间值班。所以我们的思绪确实会飘忽不定。”这读起来真是太令人失望了。哦，但这真的很人性化。你知道，我知道。我知道，但这里有讽刺意味，那就是，
I realize that when I was doing the story, and I was like, oh, people are free to project with whatever they want onto the mystery of the unknown soldier, that's of course my reputorial way of being really conceited and thinking, I'm above that and I don't fall prey to projecting anything, to this symbolism. But the minute I see the guard, I'm like, what I don't fall prey to projecting anything. To this symbolism. But the minute I see the guard, I'm like, what do I want to see?
我在做这个故事时意识到，我当时想，哦，人们可以自由地将任何他们想要的东西投射到无名战士的神秘感上，这当然是我作为记者的自负方式，认为我高于这一切，我不会陷入投射任何东西到这种象征意义上的陷阱。但当我看到卫兵的那一刻，我就想，我不会陷入投射任何东西的陷阱。对于这种象征意义。但当我看到卫兵的那一刻，我就想，我想看到什么？
I'm a reporter at 99% visible who lives in San Francisco. I see zen meditation. It's immediately what I project onto this guy. And then, of course, in the asking me anything throughout, he's just like, no, no, no, our minds wander. We think about whatever, what we're going to cook for dinner. Who knows, right? Totally.
我是99% Invisible的记者，住在旧金山。我看到了禅宗冥想。这是我立刻投射到这个家伙身上的东西。然后，当然，在“问我任何事”的帖子中，他只是说，不，不，不，我们的思绪会飘忽不定。我们想任何事情，比如我们要煮什么晚餐。谁知道呢，对吧？完全是这样。
And so, I guess the tomb has worked its magic on me as well. We think about whatever, what we're gonna cook for dinner. Who knows, right? Totally. And so, you know, I guess the, the, the, the tune has worked its magic on me as well. Yeah, thank you, Joe. All right, thank you, Roman. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Joe Rosenberg. Mix in Tech Production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Truffman, Vivian Lee, Emmett Fitzgerald,
所以，我想这座墓也对我施了魔法。我们想任何事情，比如我们要煮什么晚餐。谁知道呢，对吧？完全是这样。所以，你知道，我想，这座墓也对我施了魔法。是的，谢谢你，乔。好的，谢谢你，罗曼。99% Invisible本周由乔·罗森伯格制作。混音技术制作由Sheree Fusef负责，音乐由Sean Rial创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员是高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、薇薇安·李、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、
Taren Mazza, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Morris. Special thanks to Lou Pennebaker and Andy Richards, whose interviews were not featured, but without whose help this story could not have happened. We're especially indebted to Andy Richards' biography of David Railton, the clergyman who first came up with the idea of the tomb of the unknown warrior. The book is called The Flag, and you should check it out. We'll have more information on our website. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. 99% Invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting.
塔伦·马扎、索菲亚·克拉茨克，还有我罗曼·马斯。特别感谢卢·彭内贝克和安迪·理查兹，他们的采访没有被收录，但没有他们的帮助，这个故事就不可能发生。我们特别感谢安迪·理查兹关于大卫·雷尔顿的传记，他是第一个提出无名战士墓想法的牧师。这本书叫《旗帜》，你应该看看。我们网站上会有更多信息。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作。99% Invisible是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的、极其独立的集体。
Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, run Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But the real 99PI HQ is at 99PI.org. Radio Topia. p-i.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在radiotopia.fm上找到他们。你可以在Facebook上找到99% Invisible并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@Roman Mars，关注节目@99PI org，也可以在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上关注。但真正的99PI总部在99PI.org。Radio Topia。p-i.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。